على امل جمع معلومات استخباراتيه عن بوتين
وعن ايضا حكومته تحاول وكاله الاستخبارات
الامريكيه الوصول مباشره الى المواطنين
الروس خاصه الناقمين على وضع بلادهم
الحليب بسبب الحرب فمنذ بدء الصراع في
اوكرانيا زعم المسؤولون الامريكيون ان
سكان الروس يحاولون التواصل معهم لشرح
المظالم التي يواجهونها في بلادهم وفقا
لصحيفه واشنطن بوست الصحيفه اضافت ان
الياس بلغ ذروته مع الروس لدرجه انهم
توجهوا الى السفارات الامريكيه لعرض
مشاكلهم بل اكثر من ذلك طلب المساعده حتى
من مواطنين امريكيين في الشوارع الولايات
المتحده اعربت عن قلقها من هذا النهج غير
الامن للتواصل وقدمت بديلا في منشور حديث
على تيليجرام وتويتر نشرت وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه تعليمات واضحه وباللغه
الروسيه حول كيفيه تواصل المواطنين الروس
مباشره بالوكاله عبر
وعلى وجه التحديد متصفح الانترنت تور الذي
يتيح للمستخدمين تبادل المعلومات دون
الكشف عن هويتهم
تخاطب المواطنين الروس مقطع من دقيقتين
نشرته
الروسيه تيليجرام تحد خلاله الروس على كشف
معلومات عن بلادهم المقطع يظهر عائله
روسيه محبطه من سياسه بوتين المحتوى يحاول
التاكيد على الحس الوطني للعائله ويشجع
الروس للافصاح عن معلومات في مختلف
المجالات الوكاله في الفيديو قالت نريد
معرفه الحقيقه في روسيا وتبعث سي اي رساله
بالروسيه مفادها نبحث عن اشخاص موثوقين
للادلاء بشهاداتهم الاستخبارات الشددت على
توفير منفذ امن للمتحدثين مصادر قالت ان
الدعايه واشنطن لا تهدف لتغيير النظام في
موسكو
لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخ الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات